I'm not here to murder bend the knee and
join me or refuse and die you need to
find a way to make a listen-only no way
still run saw the night king and his
army marching towards each water bug
things are coming
bad things are coming everybody let's
break this down and be sure to subscribe
if you're finding me for the first time
so you start out with Tyrion looking
like he's really worried that Daenerys
is going to kill Jaime as well as all
the other Lannister soldiers the way
they cut it jumps around in time a
little bit so obviously they deal with
that then you hit the Varys line where
he's talking to Taran you need to find a
way to make her listen and it makes it
seem like she's going off the rails but
this feels like another version of the
drama at Winterfell which really wasn't
drama to begin with like they hyped it
up before the season so you're like is
Santa going to be fighting with Jon then
you see what that looks like on screen
so they're just trying to make Dany seem
like she's slowly going off the rails
even though I don't think that's the
case and wouldn't it be great though if
Jon Snow is the one to make her listen
because on his advice she went straight
to Jaime instead of going to King's
Landing so I know there's a big question
mark about what happened after that
battle but I think all the big
characters are still fine so you have
Bronn Jaime then you have the tarly's I
think they're fine too you see a couple
of them standing right up here at the
head is nurses talking as I'm telling
them they have to bend the knee or they
die so it seems like a little bit of a
repeat of Robb Stark mistakes maybe
Daenerys will make a couple mistakes but
I don't think that she's going to kill
Jaime I think he'll be totally fine the
producers even said the Jaime is
critical to the future of the story so
he has heavy plot armor even though he's
sinking to the bottom of that pond
however deep it is somebody will fish
them out you have Cersei who now has the
gold you only get that quick scene with
Qyburn in that offhanded line they
really lost supplies but they have the
gold to hire the golden company so it
seems like they'll be getting more
troops she was also going to use that to
bolster their other forces as well as
build more ships so it seems like a
bigger setback than it actually is but
it takes time to build all those things
even if you're you're on Greyjoy and you
can build a thousand ships overnight but
really excited to see what happens when
Jon Snow finally meets drogon this is
the first time that I think that he's
been face to face with the Dragons he's
been on Dragonstone for a long time so
he's been around the dragon but this is
the first time we actually get to see
him up close on screen he didn't look
terrified the first time he saw them
mostly just flabbergasted
but as they've been including all kinds
of subtle
winks at his Targaryen heritage his
father this would be a prime place to do
that sometimes those are a little more
on the nose and others like when the
Lords of the North say a Targaryen can't
be trusted just as Jon Snow's giving
them this big speech about going to
Dragonstone or the really on the nose
time when he says he's not a stark just
as a dragon swoops down screeching at
him if there were any questions about
what happened to Drogo like you see him
on the perch here I love the way this
looks like a nest in the background here
that's how big he is but he flew back to
Dragonstone so even though he was
wounded by the scorpion he will heal and
I know there were a lot of questions
about why would you call it a scorpion
if there wasn't poison in the stinger
so maybe Qyburn who's a master of
poisons put something on those iron
arrows it's always possible I think if
they were going to do something like
that you would find out relatively
quickly because a couple weeks seemed to
be passing between episodes
but even if drogon were to eventually
die someday the dragons are effectively
sexless like they can actually mate with
each other if they needed to so you can
actually make more dragons as long as
there were two of them still around love
the shot of Jon Snow at the map table it
feels like they made a new version of
the table for this season and obviously
they built a bunch of new sets for
Dragonstone because you've already seen
it in several different angles and
places that we haven't seen before they
built the throne room for this year all
the cave sets but you also film that
table room from different angles when
Stannis was in it before you only saw it
when it was really dark and they filmed
him against this wall with the dragon
carving in it and that was about it so
it is one of my favorite news sets and I
love the the cave set from last night to
everybody was making the joke that Jon
Snow like scribbled all those drawings
himself before Daenerys came in to
convince her but even though that's kind
of ridiculous yes the drawings did look
relatively primitive so I didn't think
that was a little bit silly but they
just want to convey the idea that the
children of the forest who used to give
obsidian to the first men probably got a
lot of it from dragon stone before there
was ever a castle or a keep there based
on the readings that Sam has done though
it seems like the Valyrians who didn't
build an outpost there till thousands of
years after the long night didn't know
anything about the origins of the
children of the forces of cave per his
readings they would add
dragonglass to their structures their
buildings without really understanding
the mythological significance to it they
just used it as a building tool but
speaking of Mythology getting into the
war for the dawn John mentions bran saw
the night king with the army of the Dead
and eastwatch-by-the-sea so that
confirms a couple things they've sent a
raven from Winterfell so he knows that
bran is there now he probably also knows
that Arya is there but the nurse is
still pissed about her war with Cersei
so it sounds like there's still going to
be a lot of back-and-forth about what
they do next
knowing that there's an army of the Dead
in how they get everybody on the same
page so this sounds like where we get to
our plan where you see Jon Snow in this
small band of people north of the wall
with torment so just a quick reminder
that the wildlings have already gone to
eastwatch-by-the-sea that's why you
haven't seen them too much this season
torment has that line where he says I
guess we're the Nights Watch now so at
some point you have to sync back up with
that storyline so we'll see how quickly
they make a beeline for the wall but
there's still all this stuff going on
with Cersei in the battle from last week
that they have to resolve first looking
at the Ravens fly over seems like it's
connected to the scenes from the trailer
that we saw earlier this year where the
night King turns and looks up watching
brand while he's watching him
so what isn't it strange they didn't
include him in the trailer so it sounds
like they just want you to think about
what's going on south of the wall is a
bigger part of the plot than what's
going on north like still pushing that
off towards the end of the season
because last week's episode was so short
we didn't get any Samwell seen so I'm
expecting him to come back he tends to
find something really cool or critical
information in every episode that he's
in so just expecting another big
revelation or a teaser bomb like Gilly
here reading all about azor Ahai them
reading about the history of the kingdom
still kind of disappointed about the
greyscale thing but whatever insert
Jorah has been making his way back to
Dragonstone it seems so maybe we'll see
him turn up too but he's nowhere in the
preview here so the only other thing I
heard people really wondering about
after last week's episode is whether or
not Tyrion is going to try and help
Jaime escape I do think that Jaime is
going to make it back to King's Landing
but I think if he did something is crazy
as releasing Tyrion the way the Catelyn
Stark released Jaime then I think that
she would be more pissed about Tyrion in
these later scenes when they're back on
Dragonstone
like I said I think there'll be a little
bit of tension between Terran and
Daenerys but it'll be tension in the way
that there was tension between John Snow
and Sansa ultimately I don't think he's
going anywhere people are like is he in
a defect what's going on no I don't
think it's going to be anything so
serious so leave all your questions in
the comments I've already gotten a
couple requests for bonus videos that
I'll probably do later this week but my
Q&A video will post tomorrow just like
normal so anything you want me to
include in that just leave that in the
comments congratulations to the latest
HBO now giveaway winner Matthew bender
please private message me on the back
end of my channel so I can get your
contact details while you wait for
everything you can click here for my
episode 4 video and you can click here
for my episode 3 video thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight